un autre favori des oscars est encore
une belle histoire
avant d'être nommé dans pas moins de
treize catégories aux oscars la forme de
l'eau et est reparti de la mostra de
venise avec la récompense suprême cette
romance fantastique un peu rétro
futuriste entre une femme de ménage
muette est un homme poisson capturé par
la cia a aussi reçu deux golden globes
d'une belle reconnaissance pour le
cinéaste mexicain guillermo del toro
philippe ce qui est formidable guillermo
del toro c'est que depuis toujours il
aime les monstres
depuis qu'il est qu'il est enfant et
leur voue un culte et et dans tous ses
films on retrouve ça et là s'exacerber
ça qui donne sa revanche à l'étrange
créature du lac noir on pourrait dire
vous souvenez dans le film de billy
wider c'est en réflexion marilyn monroe
aller voir le film sort pas embaucher de
crise quand même pour la créature elle
aurait bien ce serait bien choper la
fille est bien là ouais c'est ça c'est
comment on va faire d'une image
d'horreur c'est à dire la créature qui
emporte la jeune femme une image d'amour
et ait ce flou d'amour qui est pour les
monstres pour le cinéma envahi le film
et c'est ça que je trouve absurde du
coup pour le cinéma les années 50-60
haussier alors le siba des années 50-60
qui est partout parce qu'il regarde
l'action se passe en 62 donc il regarde
beaucoup la télé c'est le moment où la
télé commence à supplanter de cinéma et
donc il ya les films des années vient
aussi au fil des années 30 on voit des
charges est en pole il ya des trucages à
un méliès dans le film et puis l'héroïne
habite juste au dessus d'un cinéma un
cinéma ni mon pass des double programme
et c'est justement l'extrait que je vous
ai apporté parce que dans l'extrait que
je veux apporter la créature qu'elle a
ramené chez elle est en fuite
et elle va la chercher regardez il ya le
double programme là et regardez dans la
profondeur de champ il ya une marque
rouge sur une affiche et on va s'en
approcher c'est la main de la créature
qui est qui est blessé et ça devient un
jeu de piste alors dans le film il ya un
code couleur le rouge c'est le cinéma
c'est l'amour c'est la passion donc
c'est aussi le sens et regarder un peu
revue cinéma et les rouges et comme on
en 62 il ya plus beaucoup de gens qui
vont au cinéma et la créature est là
tout seul pour regarder story of truth
levine d'harry coster de 1960 qui
absolument extraordinaire espèce de film
biblique improbable et on va retrouver
là c'est les retrouvailles de sally
hawkins qui est formidable à qui donc se
joue cette amoureuse muette avec la
créature et et regardez ce
diot ou là aussi ça parce qu'elle est
formidable c'est que l'histoire d'amour
elle est très concrète 1 ils ont des
vraies relations sexuelles qu'on va voir
dans le film
alors on nous dit même après comment
c'est possible avec la créature et c'est
tout détaillé et regardez ce plan voilà
j'ai eut demandé l'arrêt images parce
que dans ce trio frousse c'est un film
biblique il ya des prêtres et c'est le
moment où les prêtres font face à la
créature est et vont la reconnaître
comme une divinité et il se passe
quelque chose entre le film dans le film
et le film à l'intérieur du film c'est à
dire que l'amour du cinéma déborde
complètement et c'est là qu'on prend
conscience que cette ce monstre n'est
pas simplement un monstre c'est une
sorte de dieu une sorte de dieu d'amour
qui vient rendre répondre c'est bien
fait dans le film bon moi je suis au
nirvana mais c'est une belle analyse
philippe malgré le moment un peu gênant
sur la sexualité de la terre c'est
inclus sinon vous vous y voyez une
lecture très politique en fait j'y vois
il ya une lecture très politique parce
que philippe le disait hier modèle toro
aime les monstres mais c'est plus aimer
les monstres il est de leur côté et le
montrent ces l'altérité mais c'est aussi
celui qui est en minorité qui souffrent
de d'un pouvoir qui l'oppressent et pour
vous montrer ça moi je vais pas vous
emmener dans un cinéma devant un grand
classique moi je vous en mets de cabinet
alors nous retrouvons donc ces deux
personnages qui sont deux femmes de
ménage une afro américaine
une sourde et muette donc voyez pas
évident est pas et pas de manière
évidente l'expression du pouvoir et bien
donc elles sont en train de faire les
toilettes pour hommes
et qu'est-ce qu'elle remarque c'est
qu'il ya même de l'uriné au plafond et
on va voir en fait selon plan qui va se
transformer en travelling
c'est un moment où même dans leurs
positions elles peuvent on va dire
appréhender cet endroit et commencer à
le maîtriser alors certes elles sont là
pour le nettoyer mais elle en rit elle
se moque de ces hommes qui arrivent a
appuyé ces mêmes hauts plafonds et petit
à petit elle se l'approprient on
pourrait avoir l'impression que ce lieu
devient un lieu où s'exerce
elle leur pouvoir sauf que ça va pas se
passer comme ça du tout et cette
illusion va les ramener tout à fait à
leur condition de femme et de femmes de
ménage voici le chef
voici sept agents américains qui sourit
qui a l'air très gentil mais qui va nous
rappeler où le pouvoir quand même
regarder cette grosse matraque ce gros
fallu soir pour mais spécifiquement
comme ça ici et là regarde bien il se
lève les mains mais il se lave les mains
pas après être allé aux toilettes avant
parce que justement c'est là qu'arrive
le symbole absolu du pouvoir on se lave
les mains avant voilà avant de remettre
des gouttes au plafond qui n'étaient pas
des gouttes du
on se moquait mais qui étaient autant
d'épées de damoclès qui pesait sur ces
femmes je peux plus me voir par quoi on
peut dire que tout ça n'est quand même
pas d'une légèreté absolue ou alors on
va peut-être en parler effectivement
doivent d'abord je vous dit j'ai pas vu
d'eau dans les extraits vous mais
montrer mari hé ben non elle a réservé
nous donne parfois mais parfois on prend
tous mais voilà parfois c'est pas
possible
alors effectivement il ya de belles
séquences aquatiques notamment
las la séquence d'amour mais alors qui
est moi j'ai l'impression que c'est un
film pour enfants tout le temps en fait
c'est ça qui me tracasse un peu dans le
dans le film par défi pour info
maintenant et bien n'augure endurante et
toy story t moonrise kingdom ces finales
est fâché avec eux c'est l'italie se
serait pas ça en fait j'adore toujours
non là ça c'est que y'a moyen moment
j'en ai un peu marre en ce moment des
comptes
j'en ai marre qu'on me parle de
l'amérique et de trump et de l'autre et
de la noirceur vient le comte limite
neutre il ya une naïveté dans le dream a
trimé chagrine un peu je trouve la
créature sublime par exemple que c'est
incroyablement candide
oui c'est vrai alors c'est bien la
candeur mais c'est un peu la forme de
l'eau de rose voyez le truc
j'ai on applaudit mais ni de la paix
maintenant date le vieux jeunes beaux et
le et le problème du sous texte
politique c'est qu'au bout d'un moment
quand dans le même objet et tu mets une
femme de ménage muette une femme de
ménage noire un homosexuel qui vient de
se faire licencier une créature
évidemment rallier nick commune oui un
communiste une créature qui sans doute
vient de du bloc du rss et tous et que
tout ça tue le confronte à un méchant
blanc avec une matraque falic
bon comment te dire c'est pas un peu
sûres écrit
vivement qu'on parle des garçons
sauvages mais justement parce que là
c'est un compte
et puis c'est bon vous êtes à table et
vous dis aujourd'hui ces steaks frites
au bois je pensais que je pourrais du
coup les frères on nous a dit que
c'était un gros lui dit vous êtes
cinémag pas les cons qui aujourd'hui se
croire dans le cinéma de croire dans la
foulée film de guillermo del toro
j'ai jamais dit qu'il fallait pas croire
tout ce qu'elle dit philippe tout à
l'heure c'est vrai mais c'est tellement
à l'écran c'est magnifique mais il
pourrait pas juste écrire un tout petit
peu plus subtilement pour après nous
proposerait lula ce qui me gêne beaucoup
dans ce que tu dis guillemette c'est que
c'est un reproche mois que j'entends à
chaque film de guillermo del toro et 5 6
ans après on les gens nous disent quand
même quand même c'était vachement bien
mais non c'était vraiment un réseau plus
moi j'adore le labyrinthe de pan
car un film qui fait vraiment peur c'est
avant tout une ambition à un monstre et
et et c'est le comble c'est pas un coup
à maris et donc si tu veux ce que je
regrette par exemple tu vois tu diras
pour une fois la la créature ya une vie
sexuelle on nous explique comment ça
marche on nous explique comment sa
marque dans une séquence un peu rigolote
et moi je regrette je n'ai aucun trouble
cette créature elle est sublime c'est la
plus belle créature de cinéma qu'on
verra cette année probablement le
vraiment tout ce qui est maquillages
costumes etc c'est somptueux
je n'ai aucun trouble son histoire
d'amour j'y crois pas la sexualité de
cette meuf j'y crois pas et je me dis
flûte j'ai pas 12 ans on est quand même
dans un film où l'héroïne se masturbe au
bout de trois médias et des tapis dans
les pièces avoir vu comment ils se
masturbent écoute voilà
voilà alors voilà du tu vois il
applaudit on y va quelles sont ses
chances aux oscars guillemette quelles
sont les chances aux oscars au board a
tout raflé aux non écoute non y aura la
torah fait meilleur réalisateur
donc un type en short jaune je suis
d'accord avec philippe non au plus il a
treize nominations donc les courses
risquent justement des douala ce film de
genre où on a mis en avant dans ce quart
techniques ont expliqué la musique est
formidable on l'a entendu là on n'a pas
eu le temps de la commenter c'est tout à
fait étonnant ce qui fait là un mot sur
les reproches qu'on fait à guillermo del
toro aujourd'hui accusations de plagiat
en amont à part de jean piat un jeune
c'est à dire que moi c'est marrant j'ai
écrit ma critique du film il ya deux
mois et je pointais deux hommages à
genêt et s était donc ils venaient
apporter les mêmes c'est à dire que le
principe du cinéma c'est que ça circule
je veux dire on va essayer de l'emmener
n'est pas lui-même recycler des fois là
bas voilà c'est la réponse de guillermo
del toro d'ailleurs oui je n'ai il dit
qu'il recycle du marcel carné tout ça
c'est c'est un peu c'est un peu normal
que ça ça brasse mme yade nous sommes
tentés mais aussi dans le film il ya une
séquence qui est vraiment reprise de
nous sommes tant aimés et moyens soient
mis mal bête c'est pas la première fois
que ça arrive un film de genre n'ont pas
grand public jeremic à un grand succès
il ya comme ça une espèce de truc quand
on est comme ça voilà des récits qui
sont en forme de conte qui sont dans le
fantastique
très souvent je remarque un c'est arrivé
à beaucoup beaucoup de réalisateurs
james cameron plusieurs fois notamment
on vient comme ça ya toujours une espèce
d'histoire de semis plagiat comme si on
oubliait que c'est les psy voilà allez
allez piocher dans des grandes formes la
forme de lots de lier un modèle toros
est en ce moment au cinéma alesi à la
nage